[Music]
time now for final exam where you pick
two news professionals against one
another to see which of them has been
paying closer attention heavy hitters
this week a fox mainstay against one of
his frequent guests bret baier one of
the best informed be best informed news
anchor in washington host special report
Mali Hemingway noted intellectual and
master of the incisive expository essay
is senior editor at The Federalist
together they make today's contestants
welcome thank you you know how nervous
we are collective I'm not gonna tell you
about it okay here are the rules you
know them but I'm gonna repeat them for
our viewers hands on buzzers I asked the
questions first one to buzz and gets to
answer you have to wait till I finish
asking the question in order to do that
every correct answer is worth one point
get one wrong you lose a point
best of five wins are you ready ready
ready alright question one Fergie
the singer upset a lot of people this
week with her jazzy and sultry rendition
we're being generous there of the
national anthem at which game did that
performance take place bret baier Fergie
sang at the basketball game almost there
at the basketball game now we're gonna
roll the tape and then ask our judges
wait your answer is that I thought you
needed the specific more specific no no
let's just roll the tape okay let's roll
the tape basketball game good news is
everyone stood for the national anthem
last night at the NBA all-star game but
some couldn't stand what they were
hearing
[Music]
[Music]
she sounds like a sober Janice I'm an
all-star I mean it was inferred okay so
I'm merely a marionette who takes
directions for the puppet masters in New
York and I'm gonna ask them now
his basketball game adequate no sorry
may I get a - you get a - oh dear all
right you're headed in the same
direction as bitcoins and I can question
- Apple is moving its employees into a
five billion dollar spaceship like
campus but the glass walls are causing a
painful problem for its workers what is
that problem
Molly Hemingway I
this breaks my strategy you're not
supposed to answer if you don't know
they hey that's sure like the SAT I'm
just gonna go with glare glare is it
glare the number of employees walking
into the curved glass walls there has
gotten so bad emergency services had to
be called workers are saying hey we're
gonna put sticky notes on some of these
glass walls indoors so people don't walk
into them
apparently reportedly their bosses took
the sticky notes off because it ruined
the design and the look of the of the
building so they're like birds they're
like they're like your cat yeah they run
right into it so for the first time in
35 year history of this show but
three-month-long however long it's been
we have a tie of negative negative one
monster in the closet question three
that's a good point after a 20-year
drought which women's Olympic team
brought home the gold today after a host
match against Canada Canada Shirley
Brett you get to answer first because
Molly Hemingway you buzzed early awesome
u.s. women's hockey team u.s. women's
hockey team against Canada winning
hockey players are in the house
are you guys 23 so the good news is
you're winning the bad news is you're at
zero anyway it's absolutely right you
don't have to be the fastest you just
can't be the slowest question for you
which Hollywood actress announced this
week she will be giving up her acting
for a year to focus on fixing our
democracy repair Jennifer Lawrence not
aware of her as an actress but we're
gonna see if you're correct Jennifer
Lawrence is the answer roll tape please
she's got a big new movie coming out of
the box office but Jennifer Lawrence
won't be acting anymore for a while
because she's decided to become a
full-time activist the stuff trying to
pass state by state laws that can help
prevent corruption fix our democracy so
now that she's no longer going to be
doing movies what are you gonna do in
the weekends good okay I'm not good at
math so I don't know where we are but I
know this is the final question are you
ready oh I know it goes fast on this
show final exam jaws dropped at London
Fashion Week after a very important
person a famous one sat next to Vogue
editor and a Wintour who's also
important and famous release famous
people are upset with Wintour for not
taking off her sunglasses and are even
calling her disrespectful who was the
head of state who sat next to her Molly
Hemingway was the Queen the queen of
Queen Elizabeth not Brunei England yeah
Queen Elizabeth is it Queen Elizabeth
Queen Elizabeth well she has never
wavered in her fashion sense her majesty
making her fashion week debut on Tuesday
sitting next to the grande Dom of all
things stylish vogue editor-in-chief
Anna Wintour at British designer Richard
Quinn's runway show you are right just
said if it weren't for that technical
error we might have a tie right now yeah
we'd be in tiebreaking territory and you
have to guess the capital of Namibia but
we're not Mali you were great thank you
that was valiant but Bret you want
congratulations with one point with one
point thank you thank you